in this world we're all so caught up in  our own heads it's easy to lose sight of  what's real  you said you don't know how much time  there is what does that mean it's  important that you realize there is a  small medical procedure involved sorry  for a game didn't expect to find myself  living in the future but you're a  [ __ ] well armed so you recently  logged your first kill and how did that  feel film Junior  you ready  if we drill down into the numbers you  have got a solid popularity arc here no  one is this happy a tuner over the  [ __ ] balloon is leda's happy  singularity guess when computers learn  to outsmart  like women did easing a few are so  virgin million pathetic as a species we  don't actually really want to kill each  other  god yeah  means fun  when should